[Music]
Hey I'm in my office sitting here with
Julie nylon and Julie you're a
professional organizer yes okay do you
know why we've brought you here
one of the producers here has a office
that's unorganized
his name is Jorden slansky and his
office is disgusting I'm also worried
about liability his office is a fire
trap we think there might be vermin not
including Jordan himself
I'm worried also maybe some of this
debris could fall onto Jordan is that
possible that Jordan could yeah it could
collapse and fall or fire leave it then
yeah another thing I'm not judgmental
whatsoever so I've seen everything you
might be judgemental after you mean
Jordan he's thing of what the word is
I want to be delicate here douchebag
does he know that we're coming I should
make that very clear Jordan doesn't know
we're coming
let's do it Jordan how are you goodness
maybe you two should meet this is Julie
Julie is a professional organizer okay
and I realize this is a surprise you did
not know we were coming that's correct
quit early because you're eating what is
this that is some commune le salami with
some coffee rub cheese on top on a
baguette
okay yeah well that's not happening now
this over here we're gonna move on to
cleaning your office okay
first impressions I could definitely
help him out we've organized the
situation about it by the way Jordan do
you mind if I eat your sandwich well you
know I wouldn't mind was it because I
was gonna eat it right but you realize
that you work for me so I can take your
sandwich if I want to
bother you that I came in here and the
camera crew you all ready to eat this
delicious sandwich if you put a lot of
work into I'm now just going into my fat
face to bother you more than me and yet
it doesn't okay Jordan let's talk about
this why do you have a charged sour
kraut sauerkraut and it's true form not
made with vinegar
it's a probiotic it's a naturally
fermented product and it increases the
gut flora
that's the intestinal bacteria the
beneficial intestinal bacteria
unfortunately modern day food have
minimized the amount of gut flora that
most people have certainly an antibiotic
side and this replenishes that be honest
and you want to hit him right now so
that was just me that one day hit it in
another face such a messy man mm-hmm
he's got disinfecting wipes and dust
wipes do you see the contrast yeah I
mean because I think he wants to be
clean and organized but he just doesn't
have the tools to do it do you think
deep down you want to be clean I'm open
to it I'm a little bit indifferent do
you think you want to be dirty not in
the way you're referring to my office
okay all right well let's start Joey why
don't you start taking charge now that
is a carbon filter pitcher of water now
I want to differentiate that from you
reverse osmosis water that we use in the
office kitchen reverse osmosis water is
not good for a coffee maker because it
has no dissolved minerals it actually
leeches the minerals from the inside of
the metal on machine therefore it's
unsafe to use reverse osmosis water
coffee machine
therefore this water which is with its
natural TDS
according to the LA water supply is
probably about three or 400 parts per
million total solids is much safer for a
coffee machine so this water is used
exclusively for the coffee machine so
this is the water for the coffee
correct and over there is the picture
for the regular water that you drink
correct this has a TDS of let's say 400
and this has a TDS probably reverse I
smell a perfect I find Utes
[Applause]
that was a product I bought that I ended
up being very dissatisfied with okay hey
Jordan you know what to give away that
this what product would be no good this
guy right here what's the bet the
giveaway for you look at me laughing at
you that you even bought this in the
first place look I'm sitting on the
couch coffee empty wine box that I'd
like to sign of an alcoholic why would
you want to keep this I use that's a
shift line how about this I use that's a
ship line as well okay this is a place
of business this is a television show
you seem to think that we are running a
moderately sized Italian restaurant you
have cheese's you have wines you have
salami
you have different waters I see very
little work going on here do you need a
separate space to keep all of your
restaurant supplies
this is garbage no oh this is garbage
Wow Julie you said that changing
someone's face can change the individual
that this could be a life altering
experience for Jordan Jordan do you feel
changed know what you don't know isn't
it possible Julie's right here tell
AuSable look em in the eye I'm like you
went to look her in the eye and then at
the last second if you show that on
replay you look down and away I suppose
it's awkward to turn my body you're
pressed up against me tightly
I'm not pressed up against you tightly
creep gee dream much bi okay do it just
saw the end of the world give your eyes
I thought maybe we could celebrate with
a little wine to Jordan's new office
congratulations
it seems you really have changed you
immensely thank you both
[Music]
[Applause]